Our VFFs, who chose today's book,
are three incredible high school students
who helped launch a groundbreaking magazine.
I've had it on my desk for the last few months.
It's called Pass the Spatula
which celebrates trailblazing chefs of color.
Take a look.
My name is Chayil and I'm 18 years old.
I am the Co-creative Director of Pass the Spatula magazine.
My name is Anthony and I am 18 years old.
I am the Marketing, PR
and social media manager for the magazine.
Hello. My name is Chris and I am 17 years old.
I was a Recipe Developer and Interviewer
for Pass the Spatula.
I go to Food and Finance High School
and my peers and I helped to create
Pass the Spatula Magazine last year.
Pass the Spatula is a spin on, Pass the Light.
It's a student run magazine
created to highlight past, present
and future chefs of color.
Often times, chefs of color usually go unrecognized
and we wanted to do our best to uplift them.
We honor these chefs of color in different ways
by showing recipes, by showing their stories
and showcasing what they've done in the past
and how we can move on from that in the future.
My main goal is to just bring the message
of Pass the Spatula throughout the world.
This is all something that we're passionate about.
Even as high school students, we can have an impact.
(applause)
It's a very well done magazine.
Please welcome, Chayil, Anthony and Chris. (cheers)
(applause)
I'm so geeking out.
I've literally been such a lover of your magazine.
I can't believe I'm meeting you.
It is such a huge accomplishment.
What you guys have made.
What have each of you personally learned
from this experience?
Chayil, I'd love to start with you.
Yeah. So for me, I know this experience has been, you know
a really good eye-opener and I know for me,
you kind of look at this experience and say,
"I have a voice," you know,
it's not just someone who has a degree,
someone who has a title.
Even if it's just like something small that you've written.
I didn't write like a whole, you know,
bunch in the magazine
but even that small little blurb I've written,
even that I'm small little drawing that I did.
I know it has an impact on somebody's life.
It really does.
And Anthony, how has it been for you?
Yeah. This experience has been really incredible.
I mean, you know, going into this magazine
we honestly didn't know what a magazine
was supposed to be like. We didn't know what the process
of creating a magazine was.
So by going into this magazine,
we were exposed to such a plethora
of different opportunities
and really it just opened up the possibilities
of food for me and my future career.
Chris, how has it been for you?
So this magazine shows that anything could happen
especially during a pandemic.
On top of that, we had the great message to show
that black chefs do matter
and do need a voice and especially the spotlight.
So especially, it was definitely great
especially during these trying times.
Well, I agree completely
and I just love the cookbook
that you picked for today's club.
It's Mix-tape Pot-Luck by Quest Love.
I have to tell you, I am his biggest fan
and this book is set up like a dinner party.
Are you guys a fan of this format?
Why did you bring it to the club, Chayil?
Yes, definitely.
I know for me, you know, when you go through cookbooks
it's probably like, all soups
or like, all salmon, like, okay, I love me a good soup
but I want to get a little bit of everything.
Like I want to get an appetizer,
an entree, a dessert and everything is in this book.
It's something that, you know,
you can see things that you've never seen before.
And another thing I love about this book
is that there's music to pair along with it.
So good food, good tunes is a great experience.
It's just amazing.
You can't have a dinner party without music.
It would be blasphemy.
(laughing)
And I love getting the opportunity
to learn from these talented chefs.
And one of the chefs in the cookbook is Kwame Onwuachi.
And you also featured him on Pass the Spatula.
And Chris, you wrote an article
and a recipe inspired by him.
Why is he such a role model for you?
Oh, from his upbringing to where he is now,
which has head chef. It definitely shows that
anything can come true with hard work
and being able to being able to know,
interview him and create the jollof rice with jerk chicken,
definitely encapsulates who he is as a person.
I have been such a Kwame fan for so long
cause I haven't missed one frame of top chef.
(upbeat music)